[Music]  hello doctor what is going on my  neighbor okay  no no get me a bad I don't think it's a  good give me the pad now you want to go  have some fun then how do you know these  people I don't she would sell your soul  for something this big it's probably  gonna kill her looping followed speed up  this pills we stole from your friend  polo boy they're a fake I told you not  to sit stand  need to get that back back right we're  gonna end up in the back of a white  panel van lined with cardboard you feel  me  I'm sorry that you got roped into all  this he's in every big  it doesn't seem like it but everything  is gonna get better  it's okay doctor  you  you